back to nuclear war
what do you think about this that people
were nonchalantly speaking about
nuclear wars if it doesn't lead to the
potential annihilation of the human
species
um
what are the chances that our world
descends into nuclear war within your
framework with you you wear many hats
yeah one
is uh sort of
the
and now uh analysts right and then one
is a human what do you think of the
chances we get to see nuclear war in
this century well you know the the
doomsday the official doomsday clock for
nuclear warfare sits in the lobby of my
building um the bulletin of atomic
scientists sort of shares a building
with us so it's it's always there every
day can you describe what the doomsday
clock is the bulletin of atomic
scientists it's it's something that this
group of physicists sort of said to sort
of mark just how close we are to nuclear
catastrophe and they started it decades
ago and it's and it's a clock and it's
sort of how close are we to midnight
where midnight is nuclear armageddon or
the destruction of humanity and
and it's been sitting i mean it's
actually it hasn't moved as close to it
hasn't moved
as close to
midnight in the last few weeks as it
probably should have only because
it was already so close there's actually
limited room for it to move for a bunch
of other reasons i think it's there's a
whole political thing that once it's
really hard it's really easy to move it
closer
and it's really hard if you're the
person in charge of that clock to move
it away
because that's always very controversial
so it always sits there but it it it
forces you to think about it a little
bit every day
and i admit i was
nonchalant about it until recently in a
way that many
many other people were
um i still think the risk is very low
but
um
kind of for the reasons we've talked
it's just so
you know unimaginably costly that nobody
wants to go that route so so it's like
the it's like the extreme version of my
whole argument with why we most of the
time don't fight is because it's just so
damn costly and so this is that's that's
the incentive not to use this and and if
they do use it that's the incentive to
use it in a very restrained way
um
but that's not a lot of but but because
we know we do go to war and there's all
these things that interfere with it
including miscalculation and all these
human foibles
and and
several of those nuclear powers are not
accountable leaders
i think we have to be a lot more worried
than many of us were very recently i
pointed out earlier like the whole
reason we're in this mess is because the
only people who have this private
interest in like having ukraine give up
its freedom is
this russian cabal and elite that
gets their
power and is preserved only and is
threatened by
ukrainian democracy
what would how far would they go to hang
onto power
when push came to shove
is i think the thing that worries me
the most and is plainly what worries
most people about the risk of nuclear
war like at what point does that uncheck
leadership
decide that this is worth it
especially if they can
emerge
from the rubble still on top i don't
know so
um and i don't know that any of us
have really fully thought through
all of that calculus and what's going on
very recently around the anniversary of
january 6 there were a lot of questions
about was the united states going to
have another civil war
on the one hand i think it's almost
unimaginable sort of like in the same
way i think that a nuclear war and
complete armageddon is unimaginable but
i remember something that uh
i when both of those questions get asked
i remember something i
i was in the audience of listening to
some great economists speak about the 20
years ago about the risk of an
argentina-style financial meltdown of
the united states like what's the total
financial collapse
and they said you know what the risk is
vanishingly small
but that's terrifying because until
recently the answer was zero
and so the fact that it's not zero
should
deeply deeply scare us all and we should
devote a lot of energy
to making it zero again and that's how i
feel about the risk of a civil war in
the u.s and that's how i feel about the
risk of nuclear war is it's higher than
it used to be and that should terrify us
all
to me what terrifies me is that all this
kind of stuff seems to happen
like overnight like super quick and it
escalates super quick when it happens
so it's not like
i don't know i don't know what i
imagined but it just happens
like if a nuclear war happened
it would be
something like a plane
like in this case with ukraine uh a nato
plane shut down over some
uh piece of land
uh by the russian forces
or so the narrative would go but it
doesn't even matter what's true or not
in order to spark the first
um moment of escalation and then it just
goes and goes well i think that happens
sometimes i mean again it's this thing
that you know
what social scientists call it selection
on the dependent variable like there's
all these times when that didn't happen
when it stopped when it escalated one
step and then people paused or it
escalated two steps then people said
whoa whoa whoa whoa
um
and and so we remember the times when it
went boom boom boom boom boom boom boom
and then the really terrible thing
happened but that fortunately that's not
you know i start off the book with an
example of a gang war that didn't happen
in in in medicine colombia which is
third that's my day job is actually
studying conflict and
gangs and violence and
of these other kinds of groups also very
sinister
and
and most of the time they don't fight
and that escalation doesn't happen so so
the escalation does happen quickly
sometimes except when it doesn't
you